-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tom Holland.
I want to talk to you.
I'm very impressed by the fact
that even with
your busy schedule,
you find time
for charitable work.
-Yes.
-Especially with your family
helping out.
Talk about
the Brothers Trust with us.
-The Brothers Trust.
Wow. I think --
The Brothers Trust is, I think,
my greatest accomplishment
in my career.
It's something
I'm incredibly proud of.
Something that also wouldn't
necessarily have happened
without my lovely mum and dad.
My mum really runs the charity.
You know, she's the driving
force for the whole thing,
but my brothers and I
are the ones that, you know,
we take up the fundraising side
of things, which is really fun,
and we do it socially
and all that sort of stuff.
And the Brothers Trust
is essentially a vehicle
to shed light on charities
that don't necessarily
get the exposure
that they deserve.
You know, there are charities
out there that are famous,
and we think that
that's kind of wrong, you know?
We want these smaller charities
that really make a difference,
day in, day out, to be helped.
So that's kind of
what we're doing.
-And it's nice.
I think a lot of those smaller,
more grassroots charities are
more connected to communities
that need their help,
and it's just wonderful
that you shine a light on that.
-Thank you.
And I mean, for us, we've got
a charity called Alex's Wish,
which is about a mum
searching for a cure
for her son's disease, and
because we know her personally,
we feel much more invested
in the cause,
and it gives us
that extra bit of drive
to go the extra way
and raise that extra dollar
to make a difference.
So it's been
incredibly rewarding.
And, also, to see the difference
that it's made
and the smiles on kids' faces
is the best thing.
-And it's really cool,
especially when you talk about
the smiles on kids' faces.
Like, you know,
one of the nicest things
about the position you're in
is, obviously,
you're playing something
that means a lot to kids.
-Yeah, of course.
-The famous Spider-Man quote,
when you have a lot of power,
responsibility is also something
you have to take
equally serious.
-Absolutely. Absolutely. When --
[ Laughter ]
No, wait, hang on a minute.
"With --"
What is it again?
-I think the way I said it
is wrong.
-I think you were right.
[ Laughter ]
-Last time you were here,
we talked about how you were
taking up golf,
and we remarked upon it
that I would imagine, like,
again, you're precious cargo.
Nobody --
Much like catching COVID,
which shut everything down,
if you got an injury,
that would be bad, as well,
for the good people
that run the studio.
Golf, they must have been happy.
They must have been like,
"Okay. I think he's gonna
be safe, injury-wise."
-Yeah, I don't think
they realize how much drinking
is involved with golf.
[ Laughter ]
-Right, right, right.
-I go and play golf,
and they're like,
"What happened to him yesterday?
He can't remember
any of his lines."
That's not true, guys.
I'm very professional.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But I love golf.
Golf is a great way
to switch off.
It's a great way
to stay competitive
while also staying safe.
-Yeah.
-You know, the day we finished
"Spider-Man 3,"
my brothers and I
flew to Montana and went skiing.
We obviously didn't tell Sony,
and then they found out,
and they were like,
"Where are you?"
Like, the top of a black run,
like, [bleep] myself.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, no.
Golf, for me,
has been a big thing.
We travel the world,
we play a lot of golf,
and it's a lot of fun.
-You got to go to the Masters.
-Yes.
-Did you -- I mean --
I would imagine the worst part
is that, at a time like that,
where you want
to watch something
and be a little anonymous,
it's obviously hard for you.
But was it cool?
Was the experience of going
to the Masters great?
-I mean, if there's ever
a silver lining for COVID,
you know, we were able
to be there at a time
where they would only let 3,000
people onto the course.
Normally, it's 60,000 people,
so for me,
it was the perfect time to go.
I kept bumping into celebrities.
Like, "Dude, how crazy is this?"
[ Laughter ]
You know?
And it was a lot of fun.
I remember being on the 10th tee
watching Tony Finau tee off,
and, for me, I'm an actor,
I live in this world,
I meet actors all the time,
so it's something
I'm not that impressed by
when I meet other actors.
But if I meet athletes,
mate, it blows me away.
And we're on the 10th tee
watching Tony Finau tee off,
and Ian Poulter just rocks up,
gin and tonic in hand,
and, honestly,
it was the highlight of my year.
It was amazing.
Just getting
all the juicy golf goss.
-Oh. If you can meet an athlete
who's willing to tell you
the stories, it is
the greatest thing in the world.
-He definitely had a few gin
and tonics, I'll tell you that.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I've always found
there's a bit of a trade-off.
Like, when I meet an athlete and
they give me a really juicy one,
then I have to give them --
I feel like they're like,
"And then could you tell me
something about show business?"
-Right, right, right.
[ Laughter ]
And you're like, "Yeah,
everyone's really horrible."
-Yeah. I'm like, "So, uh,
Tom does this lube thing."
-Yeah, right!
[ Laughter ]
-"Don't tell anybody!
He only did it twice!
He only did it twice!"
Hey, man, we were just about
to get to the place
where you were gonna
tell me all the spoilers,
but we've run out of time.
-Sure.
I can tell you.
-No, no, no.
We're out of time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're out of time!
[ Laughter ]
-I'll tweet it later.
Don't worry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys, that's Tom Holland.
-Thank you so much.
-"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
exclusively in theaters and IMAX
on Friday, December 17th.